you
an essential quality that a leader needs
to have for social change I think a
vision they have to know what they want
to change too it's not sufficient to
simply say that what is is insufficient
it needs to be some clarity about what
you want things
um i have several actually but as it
applies to children I think Miriam I
Telamon who heads the Children's Defense
Fund she clearly saw that there was a
need for more efforts and more policy
more research and more resources geared
towards the betterment of all children
and she dedicated her life to making
that happen and started a fabulous
organization that does just that
when did I realize that social justice
was a vision I think I always felt that
way I probably began to work to create
it a couple of years as a professor I
began doing some work with the Ford
Foundation and that exposed me to a
broader vision of the world and sort of
possibilities and moving out of what is
in to what can be out of what I call
descriptive ethics into prescriptive
ethics and and that was sort of that was
the beginning of it and as you can
imagine once you get on that train it's
hard to get off the largest project I
did I ran this project called the social
justice philanthropy social justice
philanthropy project and we had teams on
the ground in Kenya India Indonesia Peru
and here in the United States and each
project did something different around
social justice and studying how
philanthropy could be used specifically
to bring about more equality in the
world
what does work is the shifting of
resources and shifting a power there are
multiple forms of capital there's
economic capital which philanthropy
office is very much invested in a part
of but there's also social capital and
cultural capital and human capital and
in a capitalist society you know all
that is tied to money and I think that's
something that philanthropy does is it
is a very good job of sort of shifting
that or broadening that what I think
philanthropy doesn't always do as good
of a job of is imposing its own agenda
on to people and quite often it feels
like it's actually making a difference
when if you were to show up to a bunch
of poor people and say hey here's a
check for fifty thousand dollars if you
do X Y or Z don't you think it's a great
idea of course you're going to say it's
a great idea but it may not be something
that they want it may not be something
is actually benefit them but it makes
the philanthropist feel good
I purpose myself to partner with those
and be in the presence of those who are
doing the same thing and when you see
the product of it the process is a
little bit easier
everywhere I mean I there is no one
thing that everybody should do I think
everybody should do everything they can
there's a mantra that I've always found
annoying it's each one teach one or each
one reach one that's called zero growth
because that means for every one that
goes out only one can come in my policy
is each one should reach everyone they
can and and different people of
different passions you know I don't have
an an overwhelming passion to music
let's say you know or the arts I don't
you know have to paint or perform music
in any way or dance but there are people
who for them that's breath that's life
and my position is within use that use
that and find somebody else who's
younger and and and serve as a role
model or a bridge and opportunity for
them you know for other people it might
be sports for somebody else that might
be school whatever it is so I wouldn't
say there's one thing that everybody
ought to do